SHADOW THAT GAVE US THE RIGHTS
WE TAKE FOR GRANTED.
TOMMY ROBINSON THIS YEAR WAS
ARRESTED FOR COVERING THE TRIAL
OF A SEXUAL GROOMING BANG IN THE
U.K.
FOR SPEAKING OUT LOUD ON THE
SIDEWALK, HE WAS TAKEN TO PRISON
AND SENTENCEED TO 13 MONTHS IN
JAIL.
AFTER 2 MONTHS BEHIND BARS IN
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT AND HE WAS
ATTACKED BY JOURNALIST IN THE
U.K., BUT TONIGHT RELEASED ON
THANKS FOR AGREEING TO TALK TO
US.
YOU SPENT 2.5 MONTHS IN A SELL
BY YOURSELF.
YOU ARE PROBABLY BEWILDERED TO
BE OUT.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE FOR YOU BEHIND
I WAS TREATED.
I WAS TAKEN TO A PRISON WITH
PRISONERS.
THEY TOOK ME OUT TO PLAY GAMES
WITH THEMSELVES.
I WAS TRANSFERRED TO THE PRISON
WITH THE LARGEST MUSLIM
POPULATION IN THE U.K.
I WAS PUT IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT.
2 MONTHS I COULD NOT SEE OR
SPEAK TO ANYBODY.
THEY USED THE ARGUMENT THAT I
WAS IN DANGER.
I WAS PURPOSELY TAKEN THERE.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
IN THIS CASE, IT TOOK HOURS TO
PROSECUTE AND UNLAWFULLY
MY LEGAL VISITS AND IT WAS
MONTHS BEFORE I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO BEFORE THE
JUDGE.
ONCE THE JUDGE HEARD WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE TRIAL IN THIS
KANGAROO COURT, IT TOOK ANOTHER
2 WEEKS BEFORE I WAS FREED.
IT WHOLE ENCOUNTER, I LOST
NEARLY 40 POUNDS IN PRISON.
I HAD ONE PIECE OF FRUIT A DAY.
I WAS SUPPOSED TO BE IN HER
MAJESTY PRISON.
THROUGH THEM.
>> Tucker: WHO WAS DOING THAT?
>> I WAS ON THE GROUND LEVEL.
WHICH IT DID NOT HAVE TO BE.
EVERY PRISON WOULD WALK PAST MY
CELL WINDOW.
WHEN MY WINDOWS WERE OPEN, EVERY
PRISON IS WALKING BACK.
THE MOSQUE FOR THE PRISON WAS
DIRECTLY OPPOSITE OF MY CELL.
WE HAD HUGE HEAT WAVES.
I  HAD THOSE THINGS THROWN MY
WINDOWS.
I HAD TO BLOCK UP MY CELL
FOR ME THIS IS NOTHING NEW.
THERE ARE SOME THINGS I HAVE NOT
SPOKE ABOUT IN THE PAST.
IN 2012 I SPENT 5 MONTHS IN
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT.
THIS GOES AGAINST EVERY LAW.
WHEN I CAME OUT, I WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH A FORM OF POST TRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER.
I NEVER SPOKE ABOUT THAT
WITNESSED MORE COMPARED TO BE
LOCKED IN A CELL IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT.
THE PRISON SERVICE KNOWS WHAT
THAT DID TO ME.
>> Tucker: LET ME INTERRUPT YOU.
I WANT OUR VIEWERS TO UNDERSTAND
WHY THIS HAPPENED TO YOU IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
YOU WENT TO PRISON IN
A SUPPOSEDLY FREE COUNTRY FOR
EXPRESSING AN UNFASHIONABLE
OPINION IN PUBLIC.
IN THE LAST ROUND YOU INSPECTOR
JAIL 2 MONTHS.
-- YOU WERE IN JAIL 2 MONTHS.
DID YOU HIT ANYBODY OR SAY
SOMETHING THE GOVERNMENT DIDN'T
LIKE?
>> THERE WERE 29 PEOPLE IN COURT
FOR GANG RAPING 100 YOUNG
CHILDREN.
I STOOD OUTSIDE OF THE COURT.
I READ A BBC NEWS ARTICLE THAT
IS STILL ONLINE FOR MILLIONS OF
PEACE.
BE RELEASED.
THEY TOOK ME THROUGH THE BACK
DOOR AND PUT ME UP BEFORE
A JUDGE.
THE MEDIA SAID I PLED GUILTY.
AT NO POINT WAS I EVEN ASKED IF
I WAS GUILTY OR NOT GUILTY.
I STILL HAVE NOT BEEN TOLD AND
DON'T KNOW WHAT I AM DEEMED TO
HAVE DONE WRONG.
IN A BRITISH COURTROOM, THEY
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY ARE
BEING ACCUSED OF.
WHAT CONTEMPT OF COURT?
I WAS NON-CONFRONTATIONAL.
THE JUDGES HAVE NO POWER TO
ISSUE RESTRICTIONS ON ANY
INFORMATION THAT IS ALREADY IN
THE PUBLIC DOMAIN.
I WAS WHISKED AWAY.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN THIS WEEK THE
HIGHEST JUDGE IN OUR COUNTRY
CONDEMNED THIS AS FRAUD AND
CRITICIZED THE HANDLING OF THIS
CASE.
THE KANGAROO COURT THAT
IMPRISONED ME.
MY BIGGEST CONCERN IS WHEN THIS
HAS HAPPENED TO SO MANY PEOPLE,
I THANKED A CONGRESSMAN AND
BROWN AND TO YOURSELF, TUCKER,
PEOPLE WHO COME OUT.
IN THIS COUNTRY, YOU ARE
ATTACKED BY EVERYBODY.
>> Tucker: DID ANYONE DEFEND
YOU?
EVEN IF PEOPLE DISAGREE WITH
YOU, YOU WOULD SOME WOULD SAY
THIS MAN HAS A RIGHT TO EXPRESS
HIS OPINION.
DID ANYBODY DEFEND YOUR RIGHT TO
SAY WHAT YOU THINK IS TRUE?
>> EVERYONE IN AUTHORITY AND
EVERY MEDIA COMPANY LINED UP TO
DO HATCHET JOBS ABOUT WHY I
SHOULD BE IN PRISON AND HOW YOU
DESERVED TO BE IN PRISON.
THE WORST ONE:
AT HUMAN RIGHTS LAWYER SAID I
ARE DOING TO ME.
THEY SAID THERE WOULD BE ACID
WE ARE OUT OF TIME.
ON THAT SAD NOTE, I WISH YOU
GOOD LUCK IN RECOVERING FROM
THIS AND ON THE TIME YOU WILL
TAKE OFF.
I WANT OUR VIEWERS TO UNDERSTAND